(mumbling singing)
Doing that thing you do.
Do you guys think
that we should start a band?
- [Woman] Oh my god, yes!
- Me, you and Andy?
- [Woman] Yes!
(laughter)
(relaxed hip hop music)
That's it. Sway in the Morning.
Eight minutes past
the top of the hour.
Citizens, I've been saying all day
it's Thursday which is Friday eve in
our book at Sway in the Morning.
And every single Thursday
we do first day
with Kelly Kincaid.
Today we have a
New York Times bestseller--
- [Gary] Three time.
- [Woman] Did he just stunt?
- [Woman] Yeah, he's a stunner.
- Well here's the good news,
there's a lot of places
where you are needed.
First and foremost,
you needed to yourself.
You know?
But that's a real thing.
- [Woman] If I had to this guest
the one word it
would be dynamic.
- [Woman] Wooo!
- I appreciate that.
- Yeah, you know?
- Somebody just
Instagram messaged me,
"Hey Gary. So Mark Zuckerberg
right, has Facebook Live
170,000 strong, no hiccups.
You had 2,000, crashed all the time.
You bring him enough money
you should say somethin'.
I'm going to text Zucks right now.
Yo! What the fuck?
(laughter)
- We were looking at
the first Facebook post on your page
so funny.
- The first Facebook page post?
- Yeah.
- On my page?
- What were they?
- One of like you,
Zucks and Kevin.
- Seriously?
- Yeah.
- That's cool.
- And then the BSUs.
- Oh, the black and green
when I was in Kuwait? Yeah.
- It looks so corny
but funny, well not…
- I'm just kidding.
Yo, Andy, you why did you
call my original Facebook
post corny just now?
Tell everybody.
- Because they're corny.
Versus this?
- Fired.
(laughter)
Versus this?
Yeah but I bet you
those cornys got more
reach because that
one only got 9,000.
- That's what I saying.
I'd rather be corny and
winning then fly and losing.
- 100%.
- DRock, do one of
those cards right here.
Do that thing you do.
”That Thing You Do” is
such a good movie.
- [Woman] I think it's
Tom Hanks best.
- It is a really good movie.
- I love that goddamn movie.
- [All] Doing that thing you do.
- I know, but whats?
- Oh I tried and tried
to forget you girl.
- Andy can sing a little bit.
(mumbling singing)
Doing that thing you do.
We’ll call ourselves AGE.
Andy, Gary and Emily.
We'll be huge.
Guys, I have a shitload
of SoundCloud followers.
- Shit ton. More than Kanye.
- More than Kanye.
- Eat it.
- It's so crazy.
- Mother fucking,
Gary Vaynerchuk, baby.
- Hey Tracy.
- Yo! One of my top
five favorite humans.
Oh my gosh.
How is everything?
- Things are good.
- It's so good seeing
you in the flesh.
- Thank you.
DRock, don't break things.
- I don't know what I've
thought about you all this time,
like a frickin' hologram.
(laughter from all)
- Good Vibes!
- Hi!
- Hey good vibes!
- Nice to meet you.
How are you?
- Yeah, I won an
advance copy of
your book and I
had it on my desk
- And I was walking--
- she was like "You know Gary?"
Oh my god, yes.
(laughter)
I was like "You need to
get Gary on Sway’s show."
My peripheral vision
is so strong so
I'm walking and I was like
hold the freak up,
how did you get that?
- I had no idea.
- [Gary] That's awesome.
- And we’re linked for life.
- [Gary] I love it. I love it.
- I have so many questions,
so I was like I'm going to quiet now
so we get on the air,
but it's such perfect timing
because the girls today
opened up their conversation was
people who had
started businesses
and they didn't work
how did you transition?
What did you do next?
- [Gary] Yep.
- We're renovating our studio
so we’re in a makeshift--
- No, I'm not fancy.
- Hey! Gary V.
- How you guys doing?
- Welcome.
- Real pleasure.
How you doing?
- Passing that book out,
The #AskGaryVee the question
and answers in that book and
the MLM building organization,
what value or what benefit
are we going to have
from having that book?
- I think anybody and any
business is gonna get to see,
I talk a lot about self awareness.
I talk a lot about empathy.
I talk a lot about gratitude.
I talk about work-life balance.
I talk about parenting so there's
a lot of tactics, Ali, in there.
What you should do on Facebook,
Twitter, Periscope, Instagram,
Snapchat but then on top of it,
it's really that higher level
thinking of okay not only
here's how you can do it,
why are you doing it?
What are other ways to do it?
It's just a much deeper thought process.
Because it's like 3,
400 questions and answers
it's super tactical of both
the tactics and the religion.
Here's the religion and
here go to church on Sunday.
Got it? It's both.
- Right. Citizens you're
listening to Gary Vaynerchuk.
- Love it.
- Time to be a part of
my Snapchat show.
Some days I want to
be his mistress,
some days I want to
be his adopted child
I love them every day though.
I'll take all of those, Tracy.
(Tracy laughs)
- Thanks so much.
- You're welcome.
- Thank you. Ready?
Thank you guys. Take care.
L-
- L-A-U-R-E-N.
Thank you so much.
- Sup bro?
- Literally haven't seen you
since "Wine and Web."
- That's right.
- That's how long that's been.
- That's right. It's good to
see you, man. All well?
- Good, man.
- Good.
- Just everyday
watching your stuff.
- Thank you, brother.
- It's literally life changing.
- Thank you so much, brother.
I appreciate that.
- And DRock, too.
- DRock is the man.
- 14 is the shit.
- Thank you guys.
Thank you so much.
Take care of yourself.
Stay well.
- I'll see you at the Y, too.
- I'll see you Sunday.
Thank you, man.
I used to come here every
Wednesday night and do a show.
I did an hour on tech
and an hour on wine.
(relaxed hip hop music)
You want me to take a look at
where all the numbers and
make some recommendations
on what we should do to check
the boxes on some
extra infrastructure,
which is what I assume you
need with the assistant and
where and what kind of cost we
should be looking at for rent?
I see you Bobby Ocean.
I appreciate it.
- Gary, can I get a selfie, man?
- Yeah.
- I love you, dude.
- Thanks brother.
- Holy shit.
Good to meet you, man.
- Nice to meet you, man.
What's your name?
- Mohammed.
- Mohammed, real pleasure.
- Yeah, likewise, dude.
You're an inspiration,
dude, big time.
- Thank you, bro.
Awesome, man.
- Hey, great meeting you.
- Thanks for saying hello.
- Yeah, likewise.
You kill it dude.
- Thank you, bro.
It's so humbling.
I will never, it's so flattering.
Morning. Just a matter of time.
Thank you, Andy.
Just a matter of time, Marcus.
Hello, Court.
Just a matter of time.
Capturing this never again.
Good solid
handshake this morning.
Are you serious?
You broke your foot?
On that play?
- Yeah.
- That's the best.
I'm so pumped.
(laughter)
What's the deal with (bleep)?
Am I waiting to set up meetings?
- Let me find out.
- Sup?
- How you doing?
- Good.
This (bleep) (bleep) thing.
- Yeah.
- Hi.
Well. Good to see you again.
Can we fire Kenny?
- Fire Kenny?
Doesn't Kenny do a good job
as much as I hate to say it?
You can produce
that shit, too, DRock.
- Cool, let me know.
- (Bleep) got you going
to Westchester.
Now you're going to Jersey.
- Get me realities,
say, "Look this is what I can't get in,
what are you going to cancel?"
And I'm not going to cancel the
client stuff so it'll be after or not.
- Okay.
- I'm going to keep sending
them to you 'cause if it hacks,
people cancel, oh geez,
people cancel things
but if not, then not.
Come with us.
- Would you consider--
- Yep.
- to Israel?
- I'd definitely consider anything.
- Israel. Four is the offer.
- Probably higher unfortunately.
- Cool.
(relaxed hip hop music)
- Hi, nice to meet you.
- Hey. Gary.
I'd love to go, I don't think
I'm going to be able.
I can't do it that day because
I'm coming from Australia.
I'm going for Australia
to Cleveland, Ohio
that day.
So, I'm not sure, with a
five hour stop in Honolulu.
I can't even say Honolulu.
Anyway...
Happy Birthday, brother.
- Well thank you.
- Are you weird?
- Yeah. Kinds.
- I was weird, too.
Not that bad actually.
I was way worse at 30.
(laughter)
- Hi.
- Sup, bird?
- Sup, Gary?
- How you doin'?
- What's going on?
- I looked at my baseball
team for the first time
in 7,000 years yesterday.
- I emailed you. I told you.
I think you're making a mistake.
- About what?
- I'm not packing in.
I have a real team.
I got Aaron Judge the greatest
human being of Earth.
- Yeah.
- Who's dropped 50 spots.
- Yeah, like 50 now.
- Yeah, it's great. I like it.
- So I just need copy if any
or do you just wanna go with it?
- Put "A Chapter 1 Rant".
- "A Chapter 1 Rant"?
- Okay.
- It's on Medium so it's never
actually hit your page.
- Love it.
- We're going to do that today.
- Ok.
- And then we have
Jab, Jab, Jab,
Right Hook article tomorrow.
- Okay.
- Then we should be good.
- Thank you.
- Yep.
- What you got there?
- Sush.
Time stamp that, DRock.
That was rare footage.
The one time I've eaten lunch
on DailyVee. Was like 1 minute.
We have a meeting, right?
That I cancelled?
- Yeah, he's running a little late.
Mark was just going to get the room.
- That wasn't what I was referring to,
Joanna, but that was very good work.
That was very good work on your part.
No, no that was tremendous
work on your part.
- We're meeting tomorrow.
- We're meeting tomorrow? Good.
- I'm watching your inter--
Nice. It's a good episode.
Seth's a beast.
- I'm pumped.
- Yeah, he's awesome.
- We have a meeting tomorrow, too.
- You and I?
- Yeah.
- Just us?
- At like seven o'clock at night.
- Oh, early.
- Break my Friday night--
- But I have a Knicks
game tomorrow. Is that like?
- It's at 6:45 to 7.
- Makes sense.
Are you going to come
with me to the Garden?
- I mean I would love to.
- No, wait, that's my meeting
is 6:45 so that's wrong.
(woman groans)
- You're probably 6:47.
- I only get two minutes.
- [Woman] I'm 6:30.
- I'm going back to back with
you guys. That's amazing.
What are you guys doing?
Oh, I know what you're doing.
(laughter)
- See you, Gary!
- See you.
This guy's late and I don't know
what to do with my two minutes.
I don't know what to do
with my two minutes.
I have two minutes of down time.
- Come chill in here.
- Yeah.
- I won't bother you.
- I know.
You just work, I just work.
We'll be fine.
(laughter)
This is perfect.
- We can talk?
- Want to make a trade?
- Yeah, I do.
- What do you need?
- Everything.
- AJ! I'm loaded.
- Here we go. Three way trade.
Three way trade.
- You're loaded with a
bunch of mediocre stuff.
- Not really, man.
- And by the way, if anybody
were to have your assets
and have a chance
to win, it's you
because you'll go out
and flip three second rounders
for a star, you know
what I mean?
But, seven second rounders.
- No, no. No, bro, I'm
talking about my keepers.
Are they here?
Is my meeting here?
- I don't know.
- DeMayo, they here?
Can I get a coffee, please?
Hello.
- Hi Sam (inaudible).
Nice to meet you.
- How are you, sir?
- Peter Isiah.
- Peter, how are you?
- We briefly met.
- Yes, I remember. When
I spoke the other day.
You know, we have
clients (bleep) (bleep).
There's some there
if you want some.
They were spending all
their money on Spike TV.
'Cause they're trying to get
to the younger demo,
that's young by cable channel.
- Right.
- They were spending
millions of dollars
in production with (bleep).
They made a funny little spot,
30 seconds, and they ran it
for a year and you know how you
guys do it and the
business was down.
They heard my spiel three
years earlier than you.
We chipped away,
chipped away, chipped away.
We grew (bleep-bleep) which was
a very small brand at (bleep).
$900,000 all in, working and
non-working, 12 years flat.
We took it over,
we did Pinterest only
and a little bit of Facebook
which was unheard
of three years ago.
Pinterest is still unheard
of by most people.
- Yeah.
- And we grew the business 12%
because women are
paying attention there.
Who do you think would
win in a fight: you or Tyler?
- [Trout] Me or who?
- [Gary] Tyler?
- [Tyler] No doubt in my mind.
- Me?
- Me.
- Man, come on.
- [Gary] DeMayo, on a
serious note, who'd win?
- [DeMayo] Tyler.
- [Gary] Matt! Woah.
Trouty, hear that?
- If I got aggressive,
which I seldom do--
- [DeMayo] Yeah,
everybody says that though.
- [Gary] Yeah, everybody says
that until they get punched
in the face and they cry.
Yeah, if I get really mad.
- But if I get punched in the face--
- [Gary] Well, Trout, why
would you think fight Tyler?
You'd only fight him if you
were in a really bad mood.
- [Trout] Right but like--
- So, don't hedge it.
(relaxed hip hop music)
(street sounds)
Thank you. Thanks.
Good afternoon. So I don't
have a whole lot of time
so I figured I would do what I
normally do which is try to
reverse engineer the audience
and bring them value.
The guy bought $117
case of Pinot Grigio.
$10 a bottle Pinot Grigio.
I go in his Twitter account on this flight
and all he's tweeting is the following:
"Jay Cutler, I love you."
"Jay Cutler, you're the best."
"Jay Cutler, I'm mad at you."
For those who don't know,
Jay Cutler is and
was at the time
the quarterback of
the Chicago Bears. Right?
So he's talking about
Jay Cutler, Jay Cutler.
So I call my point person
back at the store
and I said, "Look, I want
you to go to eBay and
I want you to buy him a
signed Jay Cutler jersey."
Which was $350, much more
than the 8% profit on the $111
case of Pinot Grigio,
"and I want you to send
a note in there and say,
'Thank you for your order.
Thanks for shopping
Wine Library.'"
Great, so I send it.
And then three
and a half weeks
go by and nothing happens.
I'm like this son of
a gun is really
not going to acknowledge
this random kindness.
We send out some other stuff
and then out of nowhere,
actually, ironically,
I'm about to take stage
at a talk in Las Vegas
and I get a phone call from Kristin.
She hasn't called me yet.
She works in the
Thank You Department.
She doesn't really need me.
She's only to call me about
these couple of
things we sent out.
I pick up the phone and I go,
"You got something?"
She goes, "Kind of."
I go, "Go ahead."
"I want to read you
the order we just got."
She reads off this order
and how many people here
are into wine?
Great, wow, amazing.
(crowd laughs)
This person orders $4,800 worth
of high end red burgundy.
Coche-Dury, Duariac,
real stuff for the
real nerds in here.
Anyway, and here's what
the comment box said,
it said,
"Hey, my name is Craig.
"I want you to know you guys
"sent my friend John
a Chicago Bears jersey
"and he told me the story
"and that's how I found out about you.
"P.S. You have great
prices on red burgundy.
"P.S.S. I'm a huge
Bruce Springsteen fan."
(crowd laughs)
The punchline of that story is
you guys are curating events
and experiences that really matter.
People, today more and more as time
goes on, are sharing more and
more information about themselves.
We can cry about privacy but
everyday we prove with our actions
that we don't care.
Really, there's a much more
fascinating debate over that
which is people
are inherently good.
That mainstream
media just talks about
the small 1% of bad.
That's why we share our privacy.
Your ability to know a lot
more about the people that
are coming to these events is
far greater than
you may believe.
And that if you actually put
the time to understand who
that is, I promise you this,
that if I came to one of your
events as a top seller or
executive and I walked in to
my hotel room and
instead of a fruit basket
or a bottle of wine or
a nice welcome note
that there was
a New York Jets hat,
that would matter to me.
Because that would show the thing
that matters more than anything
which is intent and effort.
Thanks for having me guys.
Yeah, have a great night.
Thank you.
(applause)
- Thank you.
- Awesome ladies.
Thank you so much.
- It was great.
- Thank you.
- Really great.
- Perfect.
- Good, right? That felt good.
Thank you. Thank you so much.
- Thank you, very much.
- Thank you so much. Thank you.
Hey!
Really nice to
meet you, man.
- So glad. Really nice to
meet you. Until next time.
- Be well.
- You too.
- I watch your stuff
throughout the week
and for the past year now.
- Thank you, brother.
- Good stuff.
- And I'm just a
small time actor.
I'm just doing my own thing.
- Do your thing, man.
- I'm not like a business
owner necessarily.
- It translates
to everything, man.
- You motivate me so much.
I'm so psyched I
got to run into you.
- Thanks for saying hello.
Man, I wish you well.
Good luck to you.
- Thank you. Thank you.
- Zach! Take care, thank you.
This book is going to
be really interesting.
- Yeah.
- It's going to go really well.
- That's awesome.
- Thank you.
- We're still pushing all those
sales to the first week.
- Yeah.
- But if you and Alex decide
you want to move it--
- We'll change it.
- Nice work.
- Thank you.
- Vay-ner-chuk, my name is Zack Tran
and I just applied
to one of your jobs.
Now, I'm trying something
gutsy through Snapchat.
Just stay tuned I'm about
to send you a video.
- Yo, Zack! Where your video at?
Yo, Zack! Where's your video at?
(wind chimes)
- Hey Gary, my wife's water
just broke. We're just packing
up to head to the hospital.
I just wanted to say hi.
- Dude that better
not be fuckin' true
because you should not
be Snapping me when your
wife's water breaks but if
it's true, Mazel Tov. Congrats!
It's me and DRock.
Always.
- They got a skateboard
influencer that's only
available in L.A.--
- Who?
- I'm getting my whole crew out
to L.A. next week. Two weeks.
- Who? Dennis knows, right?
- He's got to. He has to.
- I'll find out.
- He has to.
- Alright, brother. Take care.
What up, gang?
- What up?
- Sorry, I'm late.
- It's ok.
- That chocolate looks so good.
(sigh) Cupcakes. God I--
(laughter from group)
- [Woman] But guess why?
It's Lauren's birthday!
(cheers and applause)
- Happy Birthday!
- [Woman] Should we sing again?
- [Lauren] No.
- [Gary] Yes!
- [Man] In 2013, we only
used 23 influencers.
Again, we were really focused
on the people that we represented.
- No, we get it.
That's the prorated math
had you stayed that exact course.
(relaxed hip hop music)
- [Interviewer] I don't even know
whether you'd be able to answer
this question, Gary, based on
your approach to this but
what do you think are the
key ingredients to a good story?
- I think the best ingredient
to a good story is understanding
what your audience wants to hear.
(interviewer laughs)
- [Interviewer] Ok, cool.
- [Gary] And so because I have
so much listening capability
and so much empathy,
I'm able to really understand
what they want to hear.
Now, what I think makes
a great storyteller is,
not a good one,
is understanding what your
audience wants to hear
and understanding
what you should
tell them predicated on that
and allowing the authentic,
most high value information
get to them instead of
pandering or manipulating them.
I'm on 44 and 6. Where are you?
Okay. 45 and 6. Alright,
I'll come to get you.
Alright.
What's up Instagram?
It's me, Gary.
Just want to say hey and
thank you from the
bottom of my heart
for all the support and
following me on the 'Gram.
That's it.
- [Interviewer] And that's a
game changer really, isn't it?
That's not always
been the case, right?
- [Gary] That's not
the case for 99%
of the people
storytelling right now.
- [Interviewer] (laughs)
Yeah.
So I think I'm playing
one big global
game of Jab, Jab,
Jab, Right Hook
and that's why I think
I've separated myself.